ma anche
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovi dove sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
un episodio di unboxing cioè delle
scatole rho in qualche cosa di
fantastico che hanno
con la presente il famoso mister j
invita l'aifa vj a presenziare se ne ha
il coraggio alla prima sfida di youtube
italia di me card in gioco c'è il suo
onore come vede nel pacco è presente
tutto il necessaire per la sfida in
trepidante attesa
mister j ma anche una mappa il mare i
delfini c'è un orso qua
ok quindi dovrei cosa figo
andiamo
[Musica]
no
ma sei tu mi hai fatto fare sto casino
incredibile sei tu capitolo stare sul
divano di casa invece poteva suonare il
campanello le persone normali no la
mappa andare in giro 12 km e fatta dalla
sedia al divano faccio ma tu sei come
sei vestita si è capito bene novak ore
prima il marocchino è finito ma poi è
molto meglio giocare qui che a casa
fidati di me qua diventa marco ti do
anche i guanti non preoccuparti vieni
qua guarda ti ho anche rubato il
portafoglio tieni pure qui non è un
problema
vieni anche questo era che perfetto
guarda non ti piacciono proprio giochi
di magia ti faccio vedere a questo si
parla di cotone si può apparire una
moneta i tiri di me
giochiamo ok in tema di giocare
giochiamo aspetta che un po di
raffreddore dai per fatti iniziamo una
sfida allora favi il gioco funziona così
abbiamo le nostre 3m car di mons
thun e dovreste avere una in tasca la
tua si chiama eva e la mia si chiama
thanatos attaccata al run evans i sì e
portafortuna da mondana thanatos questo
potentissimo e funziona così quello che
dobbiamo fare sarà lanciare le nostre
mchardy moles contro le carte e vediamo
chi fa più punti
ok se ce la facciamo
allora è capito se 21 mar di goodbye o
di lusso è bene allora dammi la mia
vediamo allora d'astico il rosso
corrisponde al punteggio io ne ero fatto
20 io ho fatto 70
la seconda è pronto 31 vai storia la
natura senza tali vi fanno benedire la
prospetta è veramente scarso l'ho fatta
e ti dirò di più che ho fatto anche
rosso cento napoli mi dispiace 50
bollino blu faccio paura è fatto tutti e
tre faccio lo faccio paura in un giro
feste e vero ho fatto 70 aspetta 20 più
cento ho fatto 170 e fatto 100 punti
impedimenti
ok per adesso vorrei per rendere la
sfida un po più difficile non sono
entrata una carta così cambiato un po di
raccordo anche mantello perché facciamo
propri figli per la le cose fatte bene e
come puoi vedere adesso le carte sono
più lontane non le prendiamo da un
centimetro e adesso vedrai di più anzi
io voglio vedrai di meno perché ti
metterai questi no vabbè erano parole e
vede in terza persona sei prove donna
idee ai suoi tre giorni per questa roba
l'hai trovato gli occhiali insomma go
per qualcosa sei pronto
vado vada mai un 5 non ci credo mai così
e io l'ho presa come saper navale non
vale mai la presa l'ha presa no
stravedo non v'è non capisco sì la presa
ragazze quando hanno fatto farlo ma ho
fatto nero 80 80 ieri ma non vale ma non
valeri 6 praticamente cieco come
cosentino della vita ok guarda sono solo
concentrato solo in posizione spetta
che se no vince tu non va bene stato sei
pronto o hai vinto tu
poi procedere una mossa fighissima
guarda adesso avrà i dieci tiri a
disposizione e io proverò ad ostacolarti
con lo skateboard
vado a bordone possibile ha preso ma
niente su dieci una prenderò sicuro ce
l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatto mio dio bravo quanto fatto
60 non è niente però per me vuol dire
tanto
adesso tocca a te le lancito io ti passo
davanti con lo skate non devi fare
questa volte fai più di me ho vinto io
ho deciso io va bene sei pronto a
mandare vado
hai visto non era così facile quando vai
via
pronto ecco come si aperto di qualità
maria è un po una magia farlocca per
l'ultima cerco di abbellire un attimo lo
stesso eccolo
perché sono bendati voti vince queste si
porta a casa tutte quante per me carico
sia contro vado
ok che dovrà lanciare ma tu sei bendato
eh no prima io vado è passato sopra ma
non la prima ci credo bene comunque sarà
presa veramente o giuro ho preso sì ma
non è o non preoccuparti guardate il
traguardo che la venia fidati di me
[Applauso]
sapere
non lo so e urlato tubi non vedo il
dritto non ce l'ho
eccolo eccolo il dritto si no senti ma
io non vedo adesso facciamo che il
cambio e metti tu questa band haven
daino preoccupati dai faccio io ma io
adesso facciamo il cambio si no non sono
pronto quante sono quattro sì vabbè
martira vado io libertà tirone il
milione
l'ho presa no ma come no no non ho mai
sentito rumori rumorino quella branca
rumori l'altro c6 questa che colore è
viola vai vai la presa no niente destra
e mancando tutti 6 scarsi ma veramente
tanti però sì ma stai mancando tutto ok
rumorino rumorino valori non devi
sentire vado tiro la presa no io ti devo
drizza un attimo la mira perché è molto
storto qualcosa insieme stortissimo è
questa la formula ricordo dalla porta
fortuna vedi che la premier
regione si è sentito rumori non ha fatto
morire niente che colore è questa qua e
blu tutte qualcosa hai preso delle cose
ma non erano quelle giuste le mancano
due cerca di tirare più dritto possibile
baita inteso così dritto partito l'ha
presa bene stavolta per forza la presa
no però ai giocatori
hai giocato benissimo non è impresa
neanche una stavolta però è andato molto
vicino molto vicino e fai più di me è
stato molto ci provare ci ha provato un
suo tempo non sei riuscito l'ha vinto io
è stato finissimo alla fine ho vinto io
le mie mchardy moblin riuscissi
andarmele tutte di sei venuto tutte
quante anche firmatarie che anche sulle
mie preferite almeno lasciami a
minacciarmi la mia fortunata thanatos
nota nato schepp
la mia favorita che ti prego almeno
lasciami la venere invito perché sono
buone se volete accettare la sfida su
instagram utilizzate lascia affronta di
tutti fateci vedere i vostri trick shot
migliori
mi piace per minuto la descrizione sono
solo i sinistri e noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video a una prossima magia
[Musica]